[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
talking ship all hand darken ship the
smoking lamp is out of object the
sickbay presents special problems in the
evening blue jackets plunged into
inactivity because they are sick or
injured grow restless during the long
days in their bunks days are long nights
longer still what can be done to ease
the tension to help the men relax till
they'll rest and sleep better
this man is tired of lying in his funk
tired physically tired mental when
you're sick the simple act of washing
your face and your hands and brushing
your teeth is refreshing and so evening
care begins with passing out the
necessary gear patients who cannot take
care of themselves are given healthy
choice
another valuable part of the evening
routine requires only a pair of trained
hands a little rubbing alcohol and a
towel a good back rub stimulates
circulation relaxes tired muscles
relieves fatigue give the patient as
much privacy as possible loosen his
clothing and turn him over on his side
or abdomen whichever is more comfortable
uncover the entire back place a towel on
the bed
or a little alcohol into your hands and
rub the back use the heels of the hands
and the fingers and rub with a firm
circular motion start at the shoulders
work slowly down the back gently but
firmly rubbing away the fatigue rubbing
away the tension go all the way down as
you rub you have a good opportunity to
observe the condition of his skin and to
be on the lookout for the reddened areas
which indicate the beginning of pressure
sores they may appear at any place where
bones come close to the surface of the
skin for instance here at the shoulder
blades or down here at the base of the
spine
when pressure sores first appear they
look like this just a red and skin area
they can usually be prevented if you rub
the danger spots frequently keep the bed
linen smooth and dry change the
patient's from one position to another
frequently so he doesn't fly on the sore
area it's neglected the skin breaks
becomes ulcerated and looks like this
finish the back rub with long firm
strokes keep your eyes open for those
reddened areas which mean the beginning
of trouble take a good look at the tips
of the shoulders at the elbows and at
the ears other likely spots are the hip
areas the outer side of the ankle and
the heels and at the knees the patient
has been well cared for and he's alright
just before you leave the crumbs are
swept out and wrinkles smoothed out
thoroughly the hospital corpsman knows
that these details are just as important
as the alcohol run the bunk is clean and
smooth and tight the alcohol rub has
stimulated his circulation and relaxed
you can see the response in his whole
attitude to care and consideration
quitting okay okay all right get some
homework for you
um not bad
beyond this welcome routine care there
may be some additional care required by
each individual patient when you're
finished all patients should be relaxed
comfortable and at ease mentally and
physically the patients come first as
they always do any unusual conditions
are reported to the medical officer then
the records which must be completed
before the ward is secured and you're
ready to be released
the senior hospital corpsman reports
today's activities to the Night Watch
and transfers to them the responsibility
of continuing the care of the patient
then the daywatch can shove off
the Nightman muster the patients and
check on their general condition they
should see that each one has been
attended to before the standing lights
are turned on at 2100
[Music]
during the long night watch especially
for the initially ill patient at least
once every hour a check is made on all
the patients to see that they're safe
and comfortable that all is secure
[Music]